I once did a television series for
Public Broadcasting called pride of
place and I realized that people were
very interested in what I was doing more
interested
the average the non architects than the
architects because the architects all
quarrelled with my interpretation as
indeed they had every right to
I was quarreling with theirs but but the
the average television watcher the
public broadcasting television watcher
could engage me to stop me on streets
and so for a long time I had the false
illusion that I was an important person
and they didn't engage me in discussion
and they because I didn't always hit
them with the word architecture like a
thunderbolt
you know the Frank Lloyd Wright I Rand
Gary Cooper movie and I showed them I
talked about things that were quite
familiar to them and how they really
were architecture and they were good
architectures I do believe the public is
intimately involved in architecture and
look at all these magazines devoted to
the residential scale which is what
people can feel engaged in on a personal
basis to build houses and apartments and
loft living and all that stuff and we
even look at the travel why do people
travel now they could say travel to sit
on beaches and things like that but why
do they go to Venice one of the most
inconvenient cities in the world
they go for the architecture and they
don't go really to poke around in every
one of those buildings because half of
them aren't even available for poking
around the inside they go for the
experience of an amazing city canals
urbanism architecture
you